[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo l'émission qui revient
sur les temps forts de l'actualité à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat nous
sommes heureux d'accueillir aujourd'hui
avec tam tran huy hervé marseille
bonjour bonjour et bienvenue et cette
âme qui dresse votre portrait hervé
marseille bonjour vous êtes sénateur des
hauts-de-seine et président du groupe
union centriste depuis 2017
vous venez d'être réélu à la tête de
votre groupe vous étiez aussi le seul
candidat à votre succession
le groupe union centriste il mélange udi
modem il ya aussi bien des élus macro
compatit que des alliés de la droite
sénatoriale résolument opposés au
gouvernement
vous vous êtes clairement un allié de
gérard larcher et malgré cela vous
arrivait à fédérer toutes les tendances
de votre groupe
certains disent même de vous chez vos
collègues et il est tombé dans la potion
magique des présidents de groupe quand
il était petit alors est ce que votre
village résiste toujours bien malgré les
appels du pied de l'envahisseur macro
nist hervé marcel l'envahisseur je sais
pas en tous les cas au sénat on n'est
pas très envahi oui
non nous nous sommes avec le groupe
union centriste clairement dans la
majorité sénatoriale avec gérard larcher
et puis le groupe républicain mais ça
n'exclut pas de travailler sur les
textes et quand ils sont bons de les
voter et quand ils sont moins bons
éventuellement macro compatibles je sais
pas comment il faut appeler ça jugé
encore une fois on est dans l'opposition
et dans la majorité sénatoriale mais ça
n'exclut pas de travailler utilement
pour le pays quand il ya des bons textes
dont les votes et on sait qu'il ya le
groupe r des pays ex lrm qui avait dit
oui quand même on aimerait bien essayer
de faire un accord de rassembler les
élus qui peuvent être macro compatible y
compris dans le groupe centriste
oui enfin toute cette crise a fait long
feu
je crois que voilà le groupe
en marche pour l'appeler génétiquement
pour ce qu'il est est un groupe qui est
une vingtaine de d'élus il défend la
politique du président de la république
quoi qu'il arrive ce qui n'est pas notre
cas
oui il n'est donc pas très attirant avec
seulement 21 lui non plus on commence
avec les titres de cette émission le
couvre-feu entre en vigueur ce week-end
pour 20 millions de français signe le
retour de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
le gouvernement présentera un texte au
parlement dès la semaine prochaine le
projet de loi de finances pour 2021 en
débat à l'assemblée l'ensemble de la
gauche a demandé au gouvernement des
contreparties face à la baisse des
impôts de production décidées pour les
entreprises et enfin le plus de la
semaine sera consacrée à votre
proposition de loi qui veut assurer la
prééminence des lois de la république et
lutter contre le communautarisme un
texte débattu lundi prochain dans
l'hémicycle et tout de suite le futur
projet de loi sur l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour instauré le couvre-feu dans les
villes où le virus progresse le plus
vite le gouvernement rétablit l'état
d'urgence sanitaire grâce à un décret
qui a été pris en conseil des ministres
la mesure entre directement en
application ce week end mais un projet
de loi va permettre de prolonger cet
état d'exception jérôme rabier un simple
décret au journal officiel suffit à
déclencher l'état d'urgence sanitaire
pour un mois mais au delà il faut un
vote au parlement
mais le gouvernement a précisé que dès
la semaine prochaine un projet de loi
serait déposé pour allonger cette durée
à six semaines
cette décision vaut pour une durée
minimale de quatre semaines et a
vocation à se prolonger au delà si le
parlement le valide sur la base d'un
projet de loi dont il sera saisi dès la
semaine prochaine une réponse aux
demandes pressantes des oppositions de
pouvoir débattre de cet état d'urgence
sanitaire et des outils de contrôle qui
vont avec
la question du couvre-feu dans son
amplitude horaire et ses exceptions
pourraient ainsi être discuté le
couvre-feu c'est peut-être une mesure
qu'il faut prendre mais c'est une mesure
privative de liberté
est ce que je veux dire c'est que pour
les français le sénat tiendra évidemment
à veiller à ce que les libertés
publiques
en tout cas les contraintes apporter aux
libertés publiques soient évidemment
très encadrée si la mesure du couvre-feu
n'est pas contestée dans son utilité les
oppositions pourrait tout de même
profiter de ce projet de loi pour
pointer les éventuelles erreurs du
gouvernement et à gauche le patron du
groupe au sénat brandit même la menace
d'un vote contre ti c'est finalement le
constat de l'incurie d'un gouvernement
je ne suis pas certain que nous voterons
nous regardons nous la vendrons nous
essaierons de l'améliorer mais à ce
stade je ne vous cache pas que mon
groupe est très réservé après avoir voté
un premier état d'urgence en mars de
l'avoir prorogé en mai puis d'adopter un
régime transitoire pour en sortir
les parlementaires sont donc ramener au
point de départ et devront à nouveau se
prononcer sur ce nouvel état d'urgence
sanitaire
hervé marseille on va parler de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire mais tout d'abord
est ce que vous êtes favorable à la mise
en place des couvre-feux écoutez moi un
peu que faire confiance au gouvernement
et puis aux autorités sanitaires du pays
quand on voit ces derniers 24 heures 88
morts supplémentaires 30 mille cas de co
vide des pistes et son supplément on se
dit qu'effectivement il est nécessaire
d'agir
excellent résultat pour vous du manque
d'anticipation du gouvernement on entend
des critiques d'autres présidents de
groupes oui exactement
moi je trouve quand même que le
gouvernement prend des décisions qui
sont lourdes de conséquences couvre-feu
c'est quand même lourd couvre-feu on
pense à la guerre on a des images dans
la tête
interdiction de sortir avoir des
autorisations pour sortir en est quand
même dans une démocratie l on n'est pas
en situation de guerre sanitaires pour
vous écouter en tous les cas tout ça est
lourd de conséquences socialement on en
parlera économiquement et puis
individuellement enfin ne plus avoir le
droit de sortir de chez soi avec
uniquement des autorisations être
contrôlés par la police si tout ça est
quand même très lourd
je trouve qu'il ya pas beaucoup
d'anticipation et je trouve que le
parlement n'ait pas suffisamment
j'allais dire sollicité on est quand
même dans un pays démocratique où il ya
des représentants là c'est vrai vous
avez du coup interrompue votre examen du
projet de loi de transitoire sur l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
parce que on a entendu parler d'un
décret en conseil des ministres sur ce
projet de loi d'état d'urgence on vous
serez saisi la semaine prochaine vous
avez l'impression qu'il ya une forme de
couvre-feu aussi sur la démocratie
bien sûr il ya quelque chose qui va pas
bien je veux dire on discute d'un texte
ce qui porte justement sur l'état
d'urgence sanitaire et en quelques
heures on vous dit on arrête tout on
fait un décret alors on agit d'abord
puis on discute après je pense qu'on
aurait pu solliciter davantage les
commissions parlementaires on aurait pu
davantage sollicité le président de la
commission des lois le président des
commissions des lois et des commissions
des affaires sociales de l'assemblée et
du sénat là il ya des questions au
gouvernement le premier ministre
dit au président du sénat attendez vous
à savoir que dans quelques heures on va
faire quelque chose vous auriez souhaité
un grand débat démocratique à
l'assemblée nationale au sénat
au moins avec les représentants des deux
assemblées je veux dire n'avaient pas
été consultées où on a découvert qu'il
avait été commis dans la télé quoi je
veux dire vous écoutez monsieur macron
pour savoir ce qui se passe ce projet de
loi d'urgence sanitaire vous allez le
voter ou pas vous allez donner c'est
pleins pouvoirs si l'on peut dire
alex et discuter un texte c'est fait
pour être discuté je pense que il est
important qu'on prenne des mesures donc
pas s'opposer à des mesures sanitaires
en revanche on peut discuter les
conditions d'application de tout ça il
faut que le parlement puisse contrôler
notamment les atteintes aux libertés
publiques
ce sont vos libertés je veux dire encore
une fois ne pas pouvoir sortir de chez
soi sauf autorisation
c'est pas rien hervé marseille entre les
attentats et la crise sanitaire la
france a vécu depuis 2015 plus de la
moitié du temps avec des restrictions de
libertés fondamentales est ce que on va
pour vous vers un état d'urgence
permanent est ce que ça vous inquiète ça
aujourd'hui oui oui c'est pour ça qu'il
faut que le parlement puisse contrôler
l'action de l'exécutif
enfin au nom de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
on fait des choses que ne permet même
pas l'urgence ça terroriste d'urgence
terroristes ces douze jours douze jours
là on va on va être un mois dans les
grandes villes avec un couvre feu
c'est à dire que c'est l'état l'exécutif
qui dirige avec la police qui contrôle
raisonnablement le gouvernement veut
même aller jusqu'à six semaines on en
parlera des buts est donc il faut que le
parlement puisse contrôler les
conditions dans lesquelles s'exerce
cette responsabilité vous vous aviez
vous nous parler de conditions vous nous
parlez de discussion qu'est-ce que vous
souhaitez mettre peut-être dans le débat
est ce que vous souhaitez que le
couvre-feu puisse commencer plus tard
peut-être à 22h c'est ce que défend
roselyne bachelot pour le monde de la
culture est ce que vous souhaitez
justement pour les libertés publiques il
y ait des libertés qui soit accordée il
faut il faut
minet tous tous ces problèmes parce
qu'on est en train de tuer toute une
profession
on va dire que j'ai culturel comme on a
tué en tous les cas quasi tuer tout ce
qui est hôtellerie restauration et pour
l'instant on aide on ne relance pas un
coût d'un milliard d'euros a dit bruno
le maire pour l'instant qu'elle se
couvre savez on cite toutes sortes de
chiffres
le plan de relance 100 milliards je
demande à voir pour l'instant il y en a
15 dans le plfr noah le reste il faudra
attendre le début d'année practice voilà
que le projet de loi de finances soit
voté pour qu'on puisse avoir 45 millions
supplémentaires donc on cite des
chiffres en pâture et on sait pas très
bien ce que cela recouvre ce que les
gens veulent savoir c'est compte tenu de
la situation qu'est ce que je vais avoir
moi alors il ya le chômage partiel qui
perdure il ya les pge les prêts garantis
qu'ils sont prorogés mais il faudra bien
les rembourser comme si les gens ne
peuvent pas travailler je vois pas très
bien comment ils vont rembourser et donc
on les maintient un peu avec la tête
hors de l'eau mais ça va pas suffire
même si c'est considérable je ne dis pas
que c'est rien c'est considérable mais
il faut aussi penser à la relance est
pour l'instant le compte n'y est pas ben
justement on va en parler de la relance
puisque l'on poursuit cette émission
avec le projet de loi de finances pour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le budget âprement débattu à l'assemblée
cette semaine les députés de gauche ont
demandé des contreparties au
gouvernement face à la baisse de 10
milliards d'euros des impôts de
production la mesure a finalement été
voté avec le soutien de la majorité
stéphanie des pierres c'est une
revendication ancienne du medef c'est
une idée défendue de longue date par la
droite le gouvernement y pensait depuis
2010 est il l'a inscrite dans le budget
c'est la baisse des impôts de production
dans l'hémicycle toute la gauche a dit
no c'est avec ça que vous prétendez vous
localiser c'est vraiment nous prendre
pour des crétins quand vous avez des
impôts de production qui représente 3,7
pour cent de la charge des entreprises
industrielles
quand c'est 0,9 dans les autres pays
européens
c'est à dire quatre fois moins vous
n'avez aucune chance de réussir la
relocalisation industrielle
ce chèque cadeau de ses voeux aux
entreprises il est concentré il est
concentré sur les grandes entreprises
les trois quarts du milliard d'euros
c'est à dire 7,5 milliards d'euros sont
pour les petites et moyennes entreprises
donc il est faux de dire que la baisse
des impôts de production bénéficie aux
grandes entreprises uniquement
oui des grandes entreprises en
bénéficient aussi et en valeur
évidemment une grande entreprise vont
bénéficier davantage pourquoi parce
qu'elles payent plus d'impôts c'est
aussi bête que cela bercy ne veut pas
poser de conditions à la baisse de ses
impôts de production mais des députés la
république en marche insiste une mission
d'information a été créé ils veulent des
contreparties environnementale ou
sociale
le ministre du budget a renvoyé le débat
à fin octobre lors des discussions sur
la seconde partie des lois de finances
hervé marseille est-ce qu'il faut selon
vous conditionner cette baisse des
impôts de production au maintien de
l'emploi dans les entreprises
non je pense pas parce que ça veut dire
qu'il faudrait s'immiscer dans le
fonctionnement des entreprises c'est
extrêmement compliqué et je vois pas
très bien comment on peut faire ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'il faut une discussion
et que collectivités locales parce que
moins d'impôts de production pour les
entreprises c'est aussi moins de
recettes pour les collectivités locales
qui sont une fois de plus entre les
mains de l'état avait taxe d'habitation
a l'impression qu'on va nous faire un
peu le coût du séisme
et on nous avait promis un million
d'emplois y en a eu 100 milles à
l'arrivée est-ce que là ça va pas être
la même chose que bongo y aura je pense
que les gars sont partis à mes yeux il
faut des contreparties mais c'est pas
concernant l'impôt de production c'est
concernant par exemple cice où un
certain nombre d'êtres directe aux
entreprises quand vous voyez bridgestone
est une qui s'envoient en fait au delà
de l'indignation
l'état ne peut rien faire pas plus que
les collectivités
donc vous voulez conditionner les aides
publiques à décrire est partie du raid
publiques directes vous allez déposer
des amendements en ce sens en revanche
de loi de finances vous pouvez
intervenir avec son parti autant sur la
partie des des impôts de production ou
de certaines taxes pour va pas rendre
entre et s'immiscer dans le
fonctionnement des entreprises c'est pas
notre rôle en revanche si vous dites à
des entreprises on vous donne une
dotation quel qu'en soit le motif
si cette entreprise quitte le secteur
dans les deux ans par exemple ou trois
ans suivant on peut lui demander le
remboursement
ouais je veux dire c'est pas rien on
donne des aides
certaines entreprises si passé un
certain délai elle quitte le pays soit
ça est-ce qu'il faut demander en
contrepartie qu'il y ait de
l'intéressement de la participation
qu'il y ait des investissements qu'ils
soient plus éco responsable écoutez on
peut on peut créer toutes sortes de
contraintes je veux dire
nous on n'est pas là pour créer des
contraintes aux entreprises
au contraire il faut qu'elles puissent
exercer leur activité librement
si on peut favoriser l'emploi ou
l'environnement bien sûr et je pense que
les entreprises sont pas non plus
insouciante de ce point de vue là mais
elles ont aussi des problèmes à gérer en
termes d'équilibré économique ou
d'actionnariat inquiets pas forcément
fiables avec le rôle de l'état aussi et
bien de d'un petit peu les forcer pour
aller vers la transition écologique
oui mais il ya déjà beaucoup de
réglementation et je pense que les
débats vont permettre peut-être de
resserrer davantage mais en tous les cas
s'agissant des contreparties à nos yeux
c'est surtout sur les aides directes
en revanche il faut aussi aider les
collectivités parce que des
collectivités qui ont moins de
ressources
c'est des collectivités qui feront moins
pour le pouvoir d'achat des citoyens
vous avez peur que l'état ne compense
pas n'ont pas confiance en faveur du
retour de la taxe d'habitation de
lui-même et bien sûr de leur appartement
d'entendre toutes sortes d'histoires tu
dis à chaque fois depuis il ya un
glissement depuis 20 ans 30 ans chaque
fois que des impôts sont transférés ou
des ressources sont transférés à l'état
l'état prétend compenser mais on
s'aperçoit qu'année après année ils
compensent de moins en moins donc il ya
un appauvrissement constant des
collectivités territoriales qui ne
peuvent plus aider les citoyens
si vous avez des enfants qui vont à la
cantine le coût du repas il est
d'environ 10 euros
les familles elles payent suivant leur
situation la moitié ou seulement 20 à
30% voire quasiment zéro pour cent mais
c'est la collectivité qui met la
différence si les ressources baissent et
que les collectivités ne peuvent plus
abonder les aides pour le sport le
social les cantines c'est un
appauvrissement de chaque citoyen
l'arrivée de jean castex n'a rien changé
dans les relations selon vous entre les
collectivités locales et le gouvernement
il n'y a pas une confiance qui s'est
instaurée comme des territoires
edouard philippe jean castex même combat
vous pensez pas qu'il y a une volonté de
de tendre la main aux collectivités
locales
pour l'instant on ne voit pas bien là
la bienfaisante retombées de ce
changement de premier ministre qu'il ait
le souci d'aider les collectivités lui
même est issu des collectivités
territoriales je lui en fais pas grief
c'est pas facile mais aujourd'hui on
voit pas bien où ça mène on n'a pas
réglé le problème de la taxe
d'habitation maintenant on nous colle le
problème des impôts de production d'état
a promis la compenser ce soit pour ses
impôts de production là encore on je n'y
croyais pas on cite tout un tas de
cheliff on sait plus où on en est là qu
est ce qui est transféré de l'état vers
les collectivités
c'est un bazar invraisemblable on sait
plus où on en est il serait temps que
les collectivités sage durablement
quelles sont les ressources sur
lesquelles elles peuvent compter autre
sujet dans cette crise hervé marseille
c'est la question de l'accroissement des
inégalités quand vous voyez à quel point
cette crise les a accrues cette
inégalité ne faut-il pas eh bien on va
faire en sorte qu'ils aient plus de
contribution des plus riches à la
relance
c'est un débat très anciens on avait
créé dans le passé lisf ça a été
supprimée on a recréé
l'ifi faudra certainement des
contributions +10 1% les plus riches la
suppression de l'isf il ya un rapport
qui est sorti il ya quelques jours pour
parler de cette qui fera certainement
regarder les contributions de chacun
peut-être faudra-t-il aggraver certaines
formes de taxation sur les les
pourcentages les plus importants de
contribuables dans notre pays parce que
ça soit un prélèvement exceptionnel une
augmentation de l'impôt sur le revenu
peut être l'un ou l'autre ça peut être
exceptionnel moi j'y serai pas opposé
comme ça écoutez quand vous voyez les
chiffres délirants
d'endettement et de dépenses qu'on est
en train de faire l'unité de compte
c'est le milliard aujourd'hui si vous
demandez pas un milliard au passé pour
être quand même très pingre donc et je
veux dire c'est terrible on est en train
de parce que parce que la situation le
on est en train d'en d'été le pays pour
nos enfants pour nos petits enfants
on sait bien qu'à un moment donné il
faudra bien quand même que ayez un arrêt
de ses dépenses gouvernementales sur la
reprise pour justement permettre de
rembourser mes lauriers matelas
croissance sera suffisante
pardon mais la reprise n'est pas là la
relance on nous en parle depuis le mois
de juillet de paix de deux plans de
finances rectificatif en plein de
finances rectificative du pélé faire 2
ou 3 puis on nous annonce un théâtre qui
aura pas lieu puis là on vient nous dire
qu'il aura lieu quand même bon
aujourd'hui la relance c'est quoi ces 15
milliards votés dans le plan de finances
rectificatif numéro trois et on est en
train de discuter dans le plan dans le
budget il n'est pas encore arrivé au
sénat qui semblait de 45 milliards il
faudra attendre le budget pour 2022
pour avoir les 40 milliards
supplémentaires donc je veux dire on
parle de 100 milliards mais en fait
c'est en trois tranches mais c'est un
budget au doigt mouillé vous êtes en
train de l'examiner sait simplement
qu'il faut faire plus vite massivement
et plus près c'est à dire que la
décision est soit pas prise dans les
administrations centrales
mais par les préfets et pour terminer à
présent cette émission la proposition de
loi constitutionnel sur la prééminence
des lois de la république
[Musique]
ce texte que vous cosigne hervé
marseille avec philippe bas et bruno
retailleau veut modifier la constitution
pour y affirmer le principe selon lequel
je cite nul individu ou nuls groupe ne
peut se prévaloir de son origine et de
sa religion pour s'exonérer du respect
de la règle commune
il sera débattu lundi au sénat qu'est-ce
que vous visez comme problème avec ce
texte hervé marseille aurait coûté
chacun voit bien que depuis un certain
nombre d'années
certaines communautés veulent faire
prévaloir leurs convictions
communautaire les marseillais pourraient
clairement tous ceux qui prônent un
islam assez conquérant et qui vous
disent dans les cantines scolaires on
veut tel type de menu dans les piscines
il faut des heures réservées pour les
femmes qui doivent s'habiller d'une
certaine façon les tenues dans la
fonction publique etc etc
il ya beaucoup d'exemples c'est modifier
la constitution pour faire face à
l'islam radical
votre proposition une conviction
religieuse quelle qu'elle soit ne doit
pas empiéter sur la règle comme une
règle commune c'est quoi c'est la loi
mais c'est le règlement ça peut être le
règlement intérieur d'une entreprise une
association on peut pas se prévaloir de
ses propres opinions
pour les imposer aux autres mais la
constitution ne nous protège pas
aujourd'hui contre ça on n'est pas au
dessus des lois de la république sait
pas visiblement c'est pas suffisant
visiblement c'est pas assez clair
visiblement c'est pas respecté ses
délais à respecter mais ça nécessite
vraiment un changement de la
constitution pour vos précisions
une précision et ce que nous souhaitons
apporter comme précision c'est quelque
chose de simple tam vous venez de le
dire c'est nul ne peut se prévaloir de
ses propres opinions
pour déroger à la règle commune il ya
sur les annonces du président de la
république sur un futur projet de loi
sur les séparatismes où il se rappellera
peut-être autrement c'est pas suffisant
selon vous pour garantir justement il
ajouté en attendant nous
avec philippe by bruno retailleau nous
avions cosigné ensemble cette
proposition février déjà mois de février
pour avoir le débat déjà et puis
rappelez cette chose simple et dire il
faut qu'une que l'ensemble des
communautés de ce pays respecte la règle
commune à l'ensemble des communautés bon
et on peut pas aller au delà de la loi
et du règlement il faut le rappeler avec
fermeté parce que sinon il ya plus de
vie commune
c'est dans ce contexte hervé marseille
que jean michel blanquer a dévoilé pour
la troisième fois les chiffres sur les
atteintes à la laïcité dans les écoles
des chiffres plutôt stable 1 nous dit le
ministre
et l'occasion aussi pour lui de faire
valoir sa fermeté sur le sujet on écoute
mais le plus important c'est que d'abord
nous sommes désormais installé dans une
logique de signalement autrement dit les
règles du jeu sont très claires en
matière de laïcité
toute personne qui voit un problème de
violation des principes de la laïcité
dans le système scolaire est en
situation de pouvoir le signaler et nous
nous sommes mis en situation de réagir
avec nos équipes valeurs de la
république qui vont dans les
établissements pour rétablir ce qui doit
l'être en matière de principes de
laïcité
vous savez nous sommes stricts sur le
sujet et nous sommes évidemment
déterminé à l'être davantage encore pour
gagner du terrain avec marseille vous
avez parlé tout à l'heure des menus à la
cantine à ce que vous êtes convaincus
par la méthode blanc caire qui dit qu'en
tout cas qu'il fait de la stricte
application de la laïcité l'un de ses
grands chevaux de bataille et cela
depuis le début du quinquennat
non mais moi je monsieur blanc coeur est
un ministre qui fait tant qu'il le peut
son travail et son métier donc sur ses
intentions je je ne doute pas un instant
en revanche il ya beaucoup de travail à
l'est dans certaines banlieues
parisiennes à l'est de paris il est très
volontariste en lançant dans wii en tout
cas dans son discours font remonter la
pente art il faut remonter la pente on a
laissé faire beaucoup de choses
aujourd'hui la laïcité a été très
malmené
si à ces débats ce soit par le
gouvernement par tout ce qu'ils ont
ce n'est là l'air tout par nous mêmes et
où à l'assemblée nationale tous les
textes qui ont été amenés sur le bureau
de chaque assemblée pour discourir de
ces problèmes c'est qu'il ya un sujet on
voit bien que aujourd'hui dans les
hôpitaux il ya des femmes musulmanes qui
ne veulent pas être
suivi par un médecin homme c'est pas
normal
encore une fois je pense que les
annonces du président à puisqu'elle
devrait permettre ça dans un futur
projet doit à à gauche on craint une
stigmatisation des citoyens de
confession musulmane qu'est ce que vous
répondez à vos collègues s'agit pas de
stigmatiser qui ce soir il ya une
situation donnée il faut bien la traiter
et on voit bien que ça pose un problème
donc je veux dire il suffit pas de faire
des annonces comme le fait le président
de la république faut pouvoir ont parlé
il ya un projet de scission sera prévu
2021 mais il faut pouvoir prendre des
décisions efficaces et qu'elles soient
respectées est-ce qu'il ya aussi des
visées politiques derrière ce type de
texte on entend à l'idée qu'il ya une
course à droite sur ces sujets bon on se
rappelle quand vous avez prendrait
présenté le texte marine le pen a tout
de suite estimé que vous reprenez la
lune de ses propres idées
avec cette modification de la
constitution je vais pas vous faire
l'injure d'imaginer qui après un
calendrier politique
enfin je veux dire tout à l'heure on a
parlé du du problème sanitaire il a bon
dos le problème sanitaire
non seulement on prend des décisions
sans tenir compte des instances
démocratiques
bientôt il y aura plus d'élection
départementales et régionales parce que
ça va arranger l'exécutif
maintenant on amène des textes parce
qu'il ya quand même des présidentielles
en 2022 et je suis pas tout à fait
innocent au point de penser que le
président de la république qui l'a pas
ça en tête peut-être une
instrumentalisation du coup du contexte
sanitaire pour vous pour ne pas avoir
les élections de 2021
je parlerai pas d'instrumentalisation je
pense simplement qu'il ya des élections
le président il doit se tenir pour vous
au mois de mars prochain
le président de la république et il
pense à l'élection du président de la
république pas lui en vouloir
on paie ses prédécesseurs ont fait la
même chose donc qu'est-ce qui fait il se
dit qu'est ce qui est bon pour préparer
les élections présidentielles tête c'est
pas indispensable d'avoir les élections
régionales et départementales parce que
mes copains ils sont pas tellement
préparés à ce genre d'élection c'est pas
bon et puis pour moi c'est peut-être
mieux si j'ai ce genre de texte pour
préparer 2022
c'est comme ça c'est le calendrier
politique matin marseille merci thème
traduit merci à vous tous de nous avoir
suivi c'est la fin de parlement et dont
on se retrouve bien évidemment la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]